Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my video all for The Last of
Us HBO series that they just announced
they dropped a teaser so I'll explain
what's going on because they also
announced that there's a new PlayStation
TV studio that's developing a bunch of
series with HBO if you're new to my
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos of course I'll be doing
episode videos for this when it starts
so we'll start with all the Last of Us
stuff and then I'll talk about the other
PlayStation TV series that HBO is
developing we'll just do this top 5
style starting with number 5 if you
missed the news on social yesterday HBO
in Naughty Dog the developer of The Last
of Us
so that they had a Last of Us TV series
coming to HBO very soon
it sort of them doing their version of
what Marvel is doing with the Disney
Plus series with the big Marvel phase 4
trailer that we just saw like the Wanda
vision trailer the Falcon and Winter
Soldier trailer the loki trailer all the
other stuff that it's working on they
haven't started filming yet but that's
basically them saying that the release
date is probably going to be sometime late
they haven't announced a cast yet so
you're free to fan cast Ellie and Joel
everyone's been all over the map the
last day with their fan cast when they
first released the game back in 2013 a
lot of people were like Maisie Williams
would make a great Ellie but now I'm
thinking that Daphne Keane from the
Logan movie x-23 would make a great
version of that character she's already
under contract with HBO for another
series so they already have her in house
and remember when the Logan movie came
out they were like Wolverine and x-23
x-men The Last of Us just saying that
the plot of the Logan movie was very
similar to the plot of The Last of Us
video game and as cool as it would be
for Hugh Jackman to play Joel I don't
think there's any chance of Hugh Jackman
doing a long-running HBO series like
this and if everything goes well I think
it'll play run for around five to seven
seasons with the standard ten episodes
per season everyone post your picks for
Ellie and Joel in the comments below who
do you want to play those characters the
person that show running the series is
the person behind HBO's Chernobyl
miniseries which I think was really
solid so I think he's a pretty good pick
he's a huge fan of the video game he
even posted his list of favorite video
games so he seems pretty legit
the original Last of Us game came out
back in 2013 The Last of Us part 2 the
sequel game is coming out in a couple of
months so that's why they're making this
HBO announcement of the series right now
just because they're capitalizing on
people getting ready to get hyped up for
the new sequel game number 4 you're all
asking during the first episode when is
the story going to pick up in the
timeline and what are the main
characters going to be during the first
season based on HBO's announcement it
sounds like the first couple of seasons
will cover the events of the first game
with potential for them to cover the
plot of the Last of Us sequel game in
later seasons just depending on how long
the series runs for. If you've never
played the game before it's an amazing
game you should try it at some point but
the story plays basically like a six
hour game if you watch all the cutscenes.
We're smuggling her?
there's a crew of fireflies that'll meet you at the capital building.
So imagine them breaking up all
the cutscenes from the game into a
couple different seasons and they're
just expanding a lot of the story
between the major WTF moments of the
games giving them more time for a
character development and bigger side
characters more side quests and
obviously the main characters of the
series are of course Joel and Ellie Joel
is a smuggler working between the
quarantine zones who's hired by the
fireflies militia to smuggle a
fourteen-year-old girl named Ellie to
their facility in Salt Lake City where
they think they can use her to develop a
cure for the fungus pathogen that's
mutating everyone into zombies
they never revealed the true origin of
the fungus as if there's some sort of
nefarious origin to it the same way that
The Walking Dead has never revealed the
origin of the zombie virus there are
some basic surface level connections you
could make between the story of The
Walking Dead and some of the stuff
that's going on during the Last of Us
because they're both post apocalyptic
zombie based stories but they're both
very different if you've ever played the
game you totally understand why but
obviously if you've never played the
game number three who are the villains
well the main villain is really the
zombie fungus itself infecting everyone
even though there are human groups of
villains that Joel and Ellie run into
along the way people are just as
terrible if you've ever watched any
Walking Dead episode you kind of get
that post-apocalyptic environment but no
joke this is actually pretty scary
there's a real-world inspiration a basis
for the zombie fungus of the Last of Us
game so there's a fungus that affects
insects by growing inside them slowly
replacing the insects organic tissue
with its own fungus while that slowly
happens it effectively turns the insects
into zombies going around infecting
other insects in his hive it's just
within the world of the Last of Us game
the insects fungus mutates and starts to
affect people then over the course of 20
years during the present day of the
story most of the world has been
affected so the outbreak isn't quite as
sudden and doesn't move quite as fast as
the timeline of the Walking Dead the
series refers to its zambese as
quote-unquote the infected mostly for
copyright issues I believe the term is
zombie is copyrighted that's also why
the Walking Dead has quote-unquote
walkers instead of calling them zombies
just for copyright issues within the
world of the story the infected usually
infect other people by biting them deep
scratches that break the skin the usual
fare of this genre the thing that really
sets the story off though is that the
fireflies militia in Joel find out that
Ellie was infected several weeks ago and
for some reason for whatever reason she
hasn't shown any of the usual symptoms
of the infected so they think that she's
got some weird genetic immunity to it if
they want to use her to try and develop
a cure to the disease but later they
find out it's way more complicated than
that
Ellie isn't immune to the disease the
way they thought that she was immune
initially I don't want to spoil the
ending of the game for people that have
never played it but there are a couple
big twists a lot of seemingly good
people and allies wind up making some
really hard choices alliances are broken
friends become enemies the typical
things that you expect from a
post-apocalyptic story like this and if
it wasn't clear as part of that HBO
teaser this symbol that they tweeted out
yesterday this is the symbol of the
fireflies militia number two though what
about the other PlayStation TV shows HBO
said it's developing they said that this
is the first of many series that is
developing with PlayStation studios what
happened recently is that Sony created a
special TV division to develop series
based on the games IP that it owns
called PlayStation studios my great hope
is that God of War will be one of those
new series it would be amazing in Sony
owns the game studio that makes the game
meaning they own all that IP that
increases its chances exponentially it's
a big deal that they own all that
themselves they don't have to pay
special license fees like HBO had to pay
too
george RR martin when they started doing
Game of Thrones the other big thing
about God of War is that it feels
different enough from Game of Thrones
that it doesn't feel like the exact same
thing.
We are not men.
We are more than that.
The responsibility is far greater.
Doesn't it feel like if they did it
right that would be the most epic thing
ever next to Game of Thrones and that's
exactly why I don't think HBO's ever
going to do an Elder Scrolls series the
medieval setting just feels too similar
to Game of Thrones and HBO's already
committed to multiple Game of Thrones
spin-offs right now first big one being
the Targaryen prequel called
House of the Dragon it's been a while
since they've given us an update on that
but I will be doing Game of Thrones
prequel episode videos just like I did
for the main series the next big one
that Sony is working on through
PlayStation TV is a Final Fantasy TV
series that seems like they should have
done that a long time ago just easy
slam-dunk with the success of Game of
Thrones people love big fantasy as long
as you do it right of course Final
Fantasy has all that the thing about
that though is that it's not going to air
on HBO Sony hasn't said where it will go
but obviously Final Fantasy is also too
similar to Game of Thrones to also be on
HBO so it'll just be on some other
network in number one the other major
easy slam dunk pick for a new
PlayStation HBO TV series would be for
them to do a Nathan Drake Uncharted
series after they finished the Tom
Holland Uncharted movie if you never saw
it Nathan Fillion himself mr. TV made an
uncharted fan film it plays a lot like a
pilot for an uncharted HBO TV series
here's a clip from that.
So what's this, then?
Our next stop.
Well, I understand the
weather in the Philippines is
particularly fine this time of year.
For those of you that are wondering yes
that was Stephen Lang that just showed
up in the Uncharted fan film and the
story behind that is that Naughty Dog
made that themselves remember they're
also owned by Sony who owns the
Uncharted IP meaning it's way cheaper
for them to develop a TV series based on
Uncharted but because the Tom Holland
movies are happening right now I think
it's going to be a little while before we
see an uncharted TV series but of course
they have one in development so everyone
just let me know in the comments how do
you want HBO to handle the Last of Us
series and who do you want to play Ellie
and Joel I'll do more videos for the
series when we get some more
announcements from them on the details
and prayed to Kratos that we get a God
of War series because that would be
amazing Marvel just made a whole bunch
of announcements about what's going on
with the Hulk in new movies and TV shows
during Marvel phase 4 click here to
learn about that and click here for my
Game of Thrones prequel teaser trailer
video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight!